toss a coin to your new Witcher a major
recasting is just rocked fans of one of
Netflix's biggest shows keep watching to
find out how fans are welcoming the new
carols with open arms or rather aren't
The Witcher has been a firm fan favorite
since first hitting screens in December
2019 following hot on the heels of HBO's
Game of Thrones the show is a strong
cult following among fantasy drama fans
the premiere season was a Smash Hit but
The Witcher season 2 proved gold for the
streaming platform her variety it
clocked up 462 and a half million hours
of view time to place it out on
Netflix's most viewed TV shows of all
time things have grown from there The
Witcher season 3 went the extra mile
managing to wrap up filming despite
tough times during covet 19. lead actor
Henry Cavill wrote on the show's
official Twitter account what a season
this has been I just want to thank you
all for your determination and
dedication to a tough shoot hopefully
you can all get some well-deserved rest
undoubtedly one of the show's main draws
is camel who provides both eye candy and
action Thrills in his role of geralt
Rivia so in the actor shocked fans by
announcing on Instagram that he was
exiting the show and being replaced by
Liam Hemsworth the reaction was less
than ecstatic in fact Cabell fans are
hitting the eject button on The Witcher
after the recast news if anyone had any
doubts about how The Witcher fans really
feel about Henry Cavill as geralt they
just need a quick glance at his
Instagram feed Cowboy wrote on his page
my journey is geralt of Rivia has been
filled with both monsters and Adventures
and alas I will be laying down my
Medallion and my swords for season 4. I
passed the torch with reverence for the
time spent embodying geralt in
enthusiasm to see Liam's take on this
Most Fascinating and nuanced man Cabell
finished by informing Hemsworth that
geralt quote has such a wonderful depth
to him and advise the Aussie actor to
dig deep and enjoy playing the character
cue the outrage one fan wrote on
Instagram and just like that the show
crashes and burns another vowed I loved
your enthusiasm for this character and
how much the series games and books I am
pretty sure I won't watch The Witcher
without you being a part of it assured
that they couldn't imagine the show
without Cabell one fan went so far as to
say this is the worst day of my life
another said they were figuratively hit
in the head by a ton of bricks after
reading his post They concluded shaking
head to clear it WTF just happened
there's no doubt that kavel did a
stellar job of bringing the lead actor
of Andre savkovsky's beloved fantasy
novel to life his replacement may not be
the man of steel but Liam Hemsworth
still has some impressive acting chops
some of the Witcher fans were kind of
almost sort of welcoming to Hemsworth a
dejected fan wrote to Cabell I'm sure
Liam will bring something to geralt but
this role was meant for you he brought
so much for the show in general geralt
will never be the same without you we
will miss you so much okay perhaps not
really that welcoming